[Vaati:] Hey, what's up guys? I'm Vaati.
[HellkiteDrake:] and I'm HellkiteDrake.
[Vaati:] And today, we are going to show you five things you *definitely* didn't know about Dark Souls.
So usually with this series, I say that if you learn something new then you should leave a like,
but honestly, you guys aren't gonna get any of these. Hellkite is amazing at digging around in the game's files,
So these are things the average person just wouldn't know.
Now it's not that I'm doubting you; it's just, don't get too upset if you don't get many, ok? You'll see what I mean.
If you still want to play the game with the like system then how about: If you learn 5 new things then you leave a like,
and if you know *anything* on the list then feel free to leave a dislike, guilt free.
Anyway, all five of these things are awesome. So let's get started, but what should we start off with, man?
[Hellkite Drake:] I think we should start off with undead King Jarr-Eel.
Number one: There's a cut or scrapped boss named Undead King Jarr-Eel.
Undead King Jarr-Eel seems to be a boss who was cut from development. His name indicates that he is either a king of the Undead or a King who is undead.
I believe it's more likely that he was a King over New Londo, which according to the Crestfallen Warrior,
[Crestfallen Warrior voice clip:] "It was once an Undead City."
The cut dialogue from Ingward Indicates Jarr-Eel may have been fought atop the church roof where Ingward ended up standing.
He's referred to as a Darkwraith which we know to be true since he fights with a Dark Hand, a tool of the Darkwraiths.
It's likely that he was the one that Ingward was referring to.
Jarr-Eel wields a Dark Hand that he can use as his shield, punch, and maybe even drain humanity with.
There's actually a level draining effect still left in the game that will flash with red text,
similar to the text that appears when equipment breaks or when you're cursed.
He also has the same sound bites as King Allant from Demon's Souls who was able to drain soul levels.
Not to mention, Jarr-Eel and the Four Kings share the same AI script, indicating that he may have been
scrapped in favor of the four kings or may have had a script repurposed for the boss fight.
The four Kings seem to wear a corrupted version of his armor with a crescent spike
coming out from his shoulder and pieces that move outwards from the middle.
The Four Kings were once rulers of humanity, corrupted by the Dark
and there are many conclusions to be drawn from the similarities between the two.
Defeat Undead King Jar-Eel and you'll get the Key to the Seal from Ingward along with his brilliant armor.
[Vaati:] Number two: as you can see Frampt and Kaathe have more animations than are currently in the game.
By replacing the model of Frampt or Kaathe over the AI of characters with attack or death animations,
you can see these terrifying and often hilarious animations.
Obviously when they created Frampt and Kaathe, they were meant to be killable enemies, but man, I'm kind of glad you can't kill them.
I prefer to think of them as these mysterious immortal beings even though they're already this goofy looking snake with a moustache.
And if this head smash animation was in the game it might have shattered that already fragile image.
And speaking of attack animations...
[Hellkite:] Number three: the living trees in the Darkroot Garden have attack animations.
They can swipe down at you with their vines.
This was probably left unused so that the trees could trick players into thinking that the path is blocked by a real tree.
[Vaati:] Number four and five both have to do with Priscilla.
Did you know that Priscilla has unique sitting and standing animations?
According to the Dark Souls Designworks interviews, Priscilla was originally going to be a sort of heroine character.
Miyazaki later elaborated saying that her role was replaced by the Fire Keepers.
A variety of sitting poses are reminiscent of the Maiden in Black from Demon's Souls who was always sitting in a different way in the Nexus.
Did you also know that every enemy in the Burg was originally meant to be Priscilla?
I'm just kidding, just kidding...
And for the final thing - this is your last chance to redeem yourself if you haven't known anything so far.
So again, according to the Designworks interviews, the Painted World was originally a prototype map, one of the first the developer worked on.
Personally, I think this is why it's such a well designed level; there's absolutely no signs that they rushed it.
There's a variety of enemies to fight, the level has great pacing, it loops around brilliantly, and there's a lot of different situations you can get yourself into.
Anyway, back on topic: the final thing you didn't know.
So in Priscilla's boss room, there's actually a 3D mesh for a breaking floor which is similar to the breaking floor where you fight the Stray Demon in the Asylum.
Not only this but we know that Nito was originally placed in the game's prototype map, which as I've said before is the Painted World of Ariamis.
So we can only assume that Nito was originally placed below this breaking floor.
There are even spiraling stairs that lead back up from the fall right below if you look at a map viewer.
So this was obviously an earlier version of Nito before he found a more appropriate home in the Catacombs,
you know, where he could wear a different skeleton for every day of the week.
And that's it! If you were playing a game with the like system, then leave a like if you learned five new things today.
And that's not all! If you're hungry for more cut content,
Then go check out Hellkite Drake's channel. His will be the first link in the description.
He has an entire series devoted to cut content so if you're looking for more, that's the place to be.
Not only that but he also makes great remixes of the game soundtrack so go check it out.
And if you're looking for more things you didn't know about Dark Souls then click the playlist link on the screen.
Cheers guys, I'll see you in the next one.
[Preview video:] Welcome everybody to the next episode of Souls News.
It's actually been a little while since I made one of these and that's partly because all of the big news right now deserves its own video.
All of which are the most recent videos on my channel so if you haven't seen those then check them out.
They're there if you didn't watch them, but for now let's open with a discussion... [sound fades out]